- Bring me the puppies!
(upbeat music)
Hi guys, I'm Noah
Centineo, and I have a film
called Sierra Burgess, hi!
"Sierra Burgess Is A Loser," and I'll
be answering some fan questions
and play with the pups.
This is the best day of my life.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
There's a part in the film where this kid
in the band is supposed
to be screaming my name,
and he's like, "Jamey!
Jamey!"
But he was like, he went
a little off the edge
with the role, and there's
a blooper reel somewhere
where he's like screaming profanities
(laughing)
and he's like, "James!
James, oh James, James."
And he was like freaking out,
and it's the funniest thing.
(upbeat music)
You know, there's a lot of great messages
in Sierra Burgess, one
of them is definitely
don't let people eat your ears.
One of them is don't let
society dictate what beauty is.
It's a really important one.
Another one is there's a really
cool part where the bully,
Veronica, and Shannon, or Sierra,
they kinda get together and
they're enemies at first,
but then they become really good friends,
and that's through
understanding each other.
And I think that's a huge, huge take away,
which is like yeah, someone
could be your enemy,
but you can't really judge someone
until you know who they are,
why they are the way they are,
and it's kinda hard to not like someone
when you understand them.
(upbeat music)
I have, it happened like
a year and a half ago.
I've met someone on Instagram,
and I developed this like
ostensively intimate relationship
with them, and then turns out
they weren't who they were.
(upbeat music)
As cat fishing does.
I learned some of it during
the process of filming.
I don't speak it, I don't sign.
But it was definitely really,
really quite an experience
getting to more about the community
and the culture of sign.
(upbeat music)
I'd say I'm closer,
bite his tale,
(laughing)
I'm closer to Jamey on my
day to day life no doubt,
and then sometimes I
can be a little Peter K
when life calls for it,
when I'm more aggressive,
when I'm more egotistical for sure.
You were never second best.
(crying)
(upbeat music)
Yo, this chick is so kind and so talented.
Wow, I'm lucky to be here.
That's pretty much how that went,
and then it was like that
the rest of the shoot.
(upbeat music)
Um.
(laughing)
She does these little like,
these little facial expressions like.
No.
(stuttering)
That's kind of my best, I'm
really bad at impressions.
(upbeat music)
I really like the kitchen scene
between Lara Jean and Peter
in Peter's kitchen, when they're kinda
opening up to each other
about their family history.
Again, the same principle of
understanding why people are
the way they are, yeah it was really great
to shoot, Lana's just an
excellent, talented given actress.
(upbeat music)
I used to do it with one of
my girlfriends in the past.
I would like, I would totally do that,
and it's just, it's very cute.
(upbeat music)
I think maybe once or twice
they were in the script,
but I say whoa, whoa, whoa all the time.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
okay, relax.
(upbeat music)
This one?
I got attacked by a dog.
(laughing)
Are these mastiff babies?
Oh okay, I got attacked
when I was six years old by a mastiff.
He ripped a hole in my face.
So you could see my teeth, my gums,
and all the way through my
tongue to the other side.
There was just a massive, gaping hole.
I specifically remember him lunging
and being pulled away from him,
and then looking back and seeing him like,
he like cocked his head like he didn't
really understand what had happened.
Some people were like yeah,
do you wanna put the dog down?
I was like crying, I was like no,
no, he didn't mean to do it.
My parents got a dog for us,
a black lab german shepherd
rottweiler mix named Mackenzie
like six weeks after the event,
and then getting another
dog, like a bigger dog
after that was like great,
now the bigger dog the better.
(upbeat music)
"Shantaram" by Gregory David Roberts.
The whole book is very
poetic, and it's a journey
from deep diving into the abyss
and then coming back
from it and transcending
and changing and learning
and it's a beautiful read.
Right now all I could
think about is the fact
that they're both making
out with my thumb.
(laughing)
I used to suck my thumb too.
I used to do it all the time.
It's a suck able thumb.
(upbeat music)
I can do this.
(clicking)
(upbeat music)
I would say
I don't know, I guess I
wouldn't give any advice
to the high school me, outside,
you know what, no, yeah, I would,
I would say don't shut down so much
after kids were a dick to you.
(laughing)
Don't like hide who you are
and maybe if I hadn't
built up such high walls,
who knows what would have been different,
but I'm pretty fortunate
and pretty grateful
for the way that my life's turned out.
Excuse me, you guys are adorable
in case you didn't know.
Okay, continue.
(upbeat music)
Zoe Kravitz.
Like ever, more than these puppies.
So much more.
(upbeat music)
Shower water.
And then I like dry it,
and I just shake it.
Whenever we were doing stuff like this
so I can talk to you guys,
there's like this spray,
this sea salt spray,
is that what it is?
Sea salt spray, that makes it look
like I just got out the ocean.
It's all fake.
(piano music)
I'm not really romantic.
That's not true, I can remember a time
where I took this girl
back to her hometown,
and we did a whole like
week and a half vacation.
I've written a good
amount of love letters.
For sure, I'm sorry, I know
you don't wanna be here,
and know I'm not the
cutest person ever, but,
but I love you.
(upbeat music)
it's a play insignia.
Like on the iPhone when you're gonna watch
one of your videos
on your video camera roll.
It's just the black with the
play and the circle around it.
Yeah.
(laughing)
I changed it because i had a picture
of my ex girlfriend on it
like almost a year ago,
and I was like, I keep thinking
about her whenever I open my
phone, so I just changed it
to that, and it's great, now
I don't even think about it.
I don't even register that I'm looking
at a picture when I open my phone,
which is one less thing to think about
a thousand times a day, because you
open your phone a thousand times.
These dogs, these beautiful
creatures right here,
are provided by Vanderpump Dogs.
VanderpumpDogs.org.
They're adorable.
Vanderpump
Dogs
.org.
Stop!
Hey!
This is not acceptable.
You do not hump your brother.
It's the girl humping the guy.
I like you killing it.
You got big dick energy.
(laughing)
Anybody heard of big dick energy?
You have it.
(upbeat music)